we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 for 750
who's next on with us hi David it's uh
Fernando on from Nevada Fernando from
Nevada interesting at there's a whole
discussion on our uh reddit discussion
forum that even though I've now made it
a point to say Nevada that that also may
be wrong but you said it that way and
you're from there so I think I'm okay
right ya know it's like I found if
anyone like trumpet telling people how
to pronounce it was wrong yesterday too
so what's an odd but that my question is
like you think since I'm thinking both
the whoever wins this election they're
probably only gonna be like a one-term
candidate early I think do you think
yeah I don't think Hillary when a filler
wind I don't think she wins reelection
arm little soon to say that there is
anything what a little soon to say that
she wouldn't win reelection mean we we
we have no idea what she's even going to
do what do you think but do you think
even though that she's already so
disliked that it wouldn't affect their
in the next election who knows I mean
you're making a good point which is we
have two candidates that are not
particularly like so if Hillary Clinton
wins and you can attribute at least part
of it part to the other guy being such a
disaster it certainly supports the idea
that maybe she would not run run for
re-election or might not win reelection
sort of two different scenarios uh but
but uh yeah I mean I think we have to
wait and see but I'm guessing that
that's not actually your question yeah
now all of them are like do you think
the next election is there's like a
greater chance for third-party candidate
to win well I said it before I'll say it
again i think really for a third party
candidate to have a real chance to be
President of the United States you need
either number one incredibly unusual
circumstances which I can't even
completely describe I mean a Republican
and Democratic candidate both under
indictment or something like that uh but
I I think instant run
voting is the way that a third party
candidate would be more viable where
people can really just vote for the
candidate that most appeals to their
politics and then say if that candidate
is not viable then switch my vote to
this other candidate I think I'm until
we have that if we don't have
significant at least campaign finance
changes it's not likely that we're going
to see a third party president yeah okay
no my question all right Fernando from
Nevada thank you so much always good to
hear from people in Nevada just was
there a couple of weeks ago and uh good
time I must say